Let's go next to. Oh, this is
interesting. Let's go to Rasmus
from Estonia. I've been to Estonia. It
is a magical place. Rasmus, you were on
are you calling from Tallinn or elsewhere?
Hello. Hello. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Yes. Good, good. Good to hear
you. I have been following you for
a month, I think, mother, but I enjoy all
your shows and everything. Thank you. Well, in
the country of Estonia. Are you?
Yes. Are you calling from Tallinn?
I know you are calling from Tartu, OK,
that's still allowed. What's on your mind?
So a few things that I wanted
to ask you. One of them is about
some of these some of these Republicans that
gets reelected and reelected despite being so
bad at their job like Mitch McConnell.
Yes. What is behind this like? How can they
keep getting reelected over and over?
It's because the state of Kentucky is a very
red state. And even with a bad candidate, you
have a population in Kentucky, a portion of the
population will never vote for Democrats.
And so you put a Republican on the ticket
and they recognize the name Mitch McConnell.
They say I'm a Republican. Mitch McConnell
is a Republican. I vote for Mitch McConnell.
It's really that simple, unfortunately, Rasmus.
Yeah, so no matter what they
do, how much they fail, know,
because of their party, they shouldn't.
And to be to be fair, a lot of those Republicans
don't think Mitch McConnell have failed. They
think he's succeeded because he's gotten so many
judges confirmed he blocked Merrick Garland from
the Supreme Court in 2016. I mean, it's not some
people don't care that he failed. Others believe
he has succeeded. And and really, in some sense,
some sense he has. Rasmus, I know you had more
questions, but I am out of time for today, so I
hope to hear from you again from the beautiful
country of Estonia. Glad we were able to take a
few calls because of a last minute cancelation.
We will take calls again, guys. And I know many
people didn't get on. That's just the reality
we all have to contend with. All right. And we
will take a quick break and be back very soon.
The David Pakman Show and David Pakman Dotcom.